you were thinking about it the whole
time it was happening before you the guy
that was had Department the one that was
yelling sure oh yeah that was that let
me tell you something if the other guy
says that the Yeller was one of the big
problems why he couldn't live with them
I might I believe him
I go well he's proven himself today to
be a crazy person but that wasn't his
complaint he became the parent for no
reason he still owes him the money so
guess what even if it was $300 a month
then guess what then he deserves
everything he wants if it's any amount
of money he should get all the money and
don't tell me the place he lived that
wasn't at least worth $300 a month so
where's that money so give him all the
money the other guys have kripp off
arnis and he knows it and he might not
be a Yeller but I bet today it brings
the rage out in them and he sees that
guy sitting there
Dalen he has a temper problem but maybe
he's right that other guy who gives a
guess what we still have a crane what do
you think we were worried that your
energy would sag after three cases but
you can really handle you can handle a
big docket
[Music]